hi there in this sample I will
demonstrate how to use the apigee maven
config plugin to push environment
configurations like Target servers key
value maps and organization
configurations like API products
developers and developer apps to apigee
using Cloud build
apigee maven plugin is a tool to create
manage apigee configurations like kbms
Target servers resource files API
products developers apps flow Hooks and
many more
please visit the plugins documentation
to find more information around what the
tool can offer
we will also be using Cloud build which
is a fully managed continuous
integration delivery and deployment
platform that lets you run fast
consistent and reliable automated bills
now for this sample the prerequisites we
will need are you should have an Apache
X provisioned and configure external
access for API traffic
now as a user you will need permissions
or roles to push configurations to
apigee like an API admin or an ARG admin
you would also need to have permissions
to trigger Cloud build in your gcp
project and finally you need tools like
gcloud unzip curl and JQ installed
this sample can be demonstrated using
the cloud shell Quickstar tutorial or
following the setup instructions in the
readme
now in this video we will use the cloud
shell QuickStart
click the open in Google Cloud shell to
open the cloud shell environment once
the environment is loaded let's follow
the instructions provided in the
tutorial
now that the cloud shell environment is
completely loaded and ready to use let's
go through the tutorial instructions
that we have on the very right the first
thing that we will have to do is do the
environment setup now to do that the
first thing we will have to ensure is
that we should have an active gcp
account selected in the cloud shell so
let's go through the login process
now once the login is complete let's
navigate to the deploy apigee config
directory
and the next step is where we will have
to update some configurations in the
environment.sh file so let's click this
link here to open the file in the editor
now let's go through the file very
quickly we have two variables that we
will have to populate one is the project
ID and the other one is the apigee
environment where we would want to push
the configurations into I've updated
this particular configuration file now
let's go ahead and save this
now that we have this file saved let's
Source this file
click authorize
and now that we have our prerequisites
complete on the instructions let's click
Start
now the first thing that we will have to
do is enable the cloud build API so
let's go ahead and enable that
after the API is enabled let's assign
the apigee org admin role to the cloud
build service account so we just copy
over the
gcloud command run it and that should be
it
and now
the final step is to actually trigger
the cloud build using the command gcloud
build submit and passing a
substitutional value which is our apigee
environment that we had sourced earlier
in the env.sh file
now this is going to take a few minutes
now going back to the cloud build we see
that it's complete we see a status is
successful now let's go ahead and make
sure that it is completely configured
the way we want it so to verify this
configuration let's log into the apigee
console so let's click this link which
should open the apigee console
and let's go back to the instructions
the instructions says that navigate to
admin environments Target servers you
should see a Target server called sample
target created similarly if you go to
admin environments key value Maps we
should see a key value map called sample
KVM so let's go check that out
so I've gone to admin environments
Target servers
yes I do see a sample target created now
let's look at the key value Maps
yes we do see a sample KVM
now for the org entities we'll have to
go to publish API products to see a
sample product similarly publish
developer to see a sample developer and
then publish apps to see a sample app so
let's go verify that now let's go to
publish API products
yes I see a sample product created two
minutes ago
let's go to Developers
we do see a sample developer and then
let's look at the apps that is a sample
app
now with that we know that the build was
successful and was able to push all the
configurations to adapt the environment
and finally we have a cleaner script so
if you would want to clean up all the
artifacts that we just created as part
of this example please go ahead and run
this cleanup script that should
basically delete all the artifacts that
we just created
thanks for watching I hope this content
was useful to you if you have not signed
up for apigee yet use this link and if
you have any questions please visit the
apigee community